Speaker 1: All right. Hundreds of you have emailed
me about my cameo in a Netflix documentary that
at one point over the weekend was the number one
show in the United States about the disappearance
of Malaysian Airlines Flight 370. And most of you
said to me, David, they're making you look like a
conspiracy theorist based on the clip and of you
and how they're using it. And yes, they are. Now,
I'm going to explain to you what's going on. I
am admitting upfront what happened here is my
fault. I could have prevented this from happening
and I'm going to explain why. But here's the big
picture. Insanely popular Netflix docu series
called MH 370, The Plane That Disappeared. I'm
briefly in it, and the clip of me is actually
of me debunking a conspiracy theory. But the
way the show is edited, it makes it look like
I am one of many people spreading a conspiracy
theory about this very flight. So let me tell
you the origins of this. Back in March of 2022,
I got an email from Raw TV and a producer
there who said, Hi, I work for Raw TV,
who are currently producing a documentary about
missing Malaysian Airlines Flight MH370. I'm
potentially interested in featuring a clip from
your YouTube video below in our documentary. Is
this something you might be interested in? And it
is. The clip is called Debunked Debunked Flight
MH370. Rothchild Patent Conspiracy Theory. This
is from Glenn. Okay. So I in general, I in general
let people use the content with attribution for
projects. This is just like a general thing that
I do. Usually they don't offer any money because
they're really low budget. But in this particular
case, they did offer money because they have
a bigger budget. So Glenn wrote back and said,
Thanks for getting back to me. I'd be licensing
a short clip for use within the documentary,
covering the following rights worldwide, all
media in perpetuity. It's non-exclusive so
you can continue to do whatever you want With the
video. I can offer an end credit and a license fee
of 500 U.S. dollars if the clip makes the final
cut. So I said, Sounds good, 500 bucks when I
usually would get zero and say, use it as long
as you credit me. That sounds absolutely fine.
The problem is that in the documentary, they
include me in a context that makes it seem as
though I am perpetuating the conspiracy theory.
Here is the clip. Take a look. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: His wife news has just broken. A
fisherman from Indonesia saw the damaged plane
covered in black smoke as it flew overhead.
Speaker 8: Another conspiracy, an outrageous
insurance scam. Some of these people showed
up outside my office who were chasing down
in a carpark. It was quite scary. I was reading an
angle, one strange escape, one of these people who
really just wanted to bring their theory to me.
Speaker 1: Four days after the flight disappeared,
there was a pattern issued for
a new semiconductor technology.
Speaker 8: Others wonder, did it land on the U.S.?
Speaker 1: Okay, so they include me in this list
of conspiracy theories, and then they show a guy
looking at it and then the guy clicks share. The
idea being that I was part of the spread of
conspiracy theories. The reality, of course,
is the entire video was debunking that very
conspiracy theory. This would be sort of like
if I said one of the most disgusting things
that neo-Nazis say is Jews are blah, blah,
blah. And then you just cut out where I quote the
neo-Nazi, and you include me in a montage where I
say, Jews do blah, blah, blah, and then I'm now
part of the of the neo-Nazi conspiracy theory or
whatever the case may be. Now, ultimately, this
is my fault, and I'll explain why. Yes, they
knew they were being dishonest. The title says
debunked, and they make it seem like I am banking
rather than debunking. But I should have requested
something in the license. That said, a lawyer
emailed me about this. I should have requested
something that in the licensing agreement
I tailored the specific use rather than giving a
general license. I should have said the context
must be one that makes clear that I am debunking
rather than spreading and that I don't believe
this conspiracy theory I am quoting. I didn't do
that now. I lived and I learned they paid the 500
bucks, they got their license, and now it's one
of the biggest shows on Netflix. And it makes me
look like a conspiracy theory theorist. So I
certainly learned a lesson. That being said,
another lawyer reached out and said, David, it's
fine that you're blaming yourself. I mentioned
this on yesterday's stream. It's fine that you're
blaming yourself for not getting a more specific
license, but the truth is they still deliberately
and maliciously mis edited that in order to make
it seem like you're saying the opposite of what
you're saying, you actually could sue them.
Should I sue is the question. I don't know.
Sounds like it could be an. Interesting story,
so maybe I should, but I'm not super inclined
to do that. I will follow up with this
if I have the opportunity, if
there's anything to tell you.